[Music]
can you believe that in August it'll be
20 years since my 70 show from aired
this you said yes it feels like it you
know why because I'm that crazy I had 16
year olds being like I love your show
and I do the math and I'm like oh that's
weird
because you weren't born like it's when
I when I start doing the math of like
people that cuz of Netflix or whatever
it is that it's rerunning on make me
feel really old guys I won't lie I'm
like oh I'm not as young as I once was
age of reboot
I'm gonna am but - yes it's weird would
you guys ever do it again I mean there's
it's reboot mania right now as our
characters
no listen ha I married my boyfriend in
the show so it's not like you know I am
story it's it's real life I am you know
maybe I can't say no because we're all
still very good friends the world in
such different places in our life but I
guess when I was interesting as Roseanne
nobody wants to see us back together be
like 1990s
my husband what am I supposed to say yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]